[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello martin
i got you this time
hello walter so
how many episodes are we still gonna do
i hope hopefully only one
and then the lord comes but if it
doesn't come then who knows how many
right yeah it's up to him yes it's up to
him
so what how have you been
i have to get that in
i'm fine thank you good
let's open with a word of prayer
our heavenly father thank you very much
for once again bringing us together
thank you for giving us these
opportunities
we can only do this in the strength that
you give so we ask that you enlighten
our minds with the holy spirit and bless
this discussion in jesus name amen amen
well martin
we've called this one known duty right
correct it always sounds so ominous
shall we rather just leave it and go
home what shall we do yeah yeah
if you
let the lord
work his will
is it all it's not always
in line with your will i see it makes it
a little bit difficult the fallen nature
doesn't
come into line very easily
no no no and
you have to trust the lord even in the
little things
and give over the little things to him
because
on my personal journey
it's always at the small and little
things that it gets difficult it's small
decisions along the way
that become cumulative yeah
so let's jump into exodus
because martin the exodus
is
salvation in type out of egypt
come out of egypt he took his people out
of egypt
and we're living in a time where he says
come out of babylon yes so we've gone
from a local to a universal
that's what it is right
and if we look at exodus chapter 4 from
verse 18 onwards the lord said unto
moses in midian
go return into egypt for all the men are
dead which sought thy life
and moses took his wife and his sons and
set them upon an ass
and he returned to the land of egypt
and moses took the rod of god in his
hand i'd been in median for 40 years
right
and he'd communed with god
he'd written a number of things yeah yes
the book of job for sure
and he had a very close walk with god
and had a change of mindset he had 40
years
to mellow away his egyptian roots
but they were useful to him
because he had all the wisdom of the
egyptians correct now martin that's an
important point yeah
people always say
why do you study these things it's not
necessarily necessary to know any of
those things yes
was it useful to
moses that he understood the might set
of the egyptians
i think god put him there especially to
have learned that
otherwise he couldn't have done what he
did when he was back he attended the
university there i don't know maybe it
was the university of luxor
and he was trained in all the wisdom of
the egyptians
and he was a military man
so he knew exactly how they go about
warfare
is it important to understand your enemy
yes you think so very important
if you don't understand your enemy you
won't know what what you're up against
yeah you know in
krita malta
i discussed
the art of war
and if you do not understand the art of
war and you have no idea where the enemy
is coming from
then uh you could be very confused right
correct okay
do you think that the angels and jesus
were well acquainted with the wilds of
the devil yes
did they warn
adam and eve yeah
about his tactics and what he will do
and where he will be and that they
shouldn't listen to him definitely if
you read the spirit of prophecy it says
that
adam and eve were in constant communion
with the angel angels and god correct
and if you're standing on the walls of
zions you're looking out to see what the
enemy is going to do right exactly what
is the watchman's duty that's right so
let's just take it from there
and thou shalt say unto pharaoh
thus says the lord israel is my son even
my firstborn
that means he's the one of prime
prominence
he's unique unique
and i say unto thee let my son go that
he may serve men if thou refuse to let
him go behold i will slay thy son even
thy firstborn
so martin here's a reference
to the tenth plague
right from the onset right now that's a
that's a
pretty dire warning
did god do it immediately or did he
wait
no he waited
ten plagues right they had nine before
they had to suffer that they had many a
warning so nobody can say god was unfair
no
and it came to pass by the way in the
inn that the lord met him and sought to
kill him
then zipper took a sharp stone and cut
off the foreskin of her son and cast it
at his feet and said surely a bloody
husband ought thou to me
so he that is god
let him go
then she said a bloody husband thou art
because of the circumcision
now this verse has caused quite a lot of
debate in the world
was she
displaying a fit of rage here
why did she do it and not he do it
because it was really his duty to do it
as the husband
and
obviously his sons his other sons had
been circumcised
it's not absolutely clear whether they
had been before
or just previously or whatever but
obviously some people say that zipra was
very anti the circumcision she probably
was
because she didn't fully understand the
meaning thereof
but
some people think that she's basically
cursing her husband here
and it's repeated twice right
and if you look at the various
commentaries then that is the idea that
is put forth and some people also might
get confused on the
part that said god sought to kill him
correct
now nobody really knows in what way
god sought to kill him there
did he
appear like the angel of the lord with
his sword ready to kill him
or was this a more
subtle way which they understood did he
strike him down with the disease
that's a good possibility yes
so that he was totally helpless
and dying yeah
so he had no way
of circumcising his son
so either zipper did it for him or moses
would have died
now why was god so drastic
in his action over here
so if we go and look at the comments on
this section
and i always like to go to you know
sources that
you know had a spiritual connection with
god
so either the spirit of prophecy or
wesley or luther or one of those
or a pioneer perhaps
so he let him go wesley says the
destroying angel withdrew but still
zipper cannot forget
but will unreasonably call moses a
bloody husband so wesley thought that
he was
basically in a position where she was
very unhappy
and basically cussed a little bit yeah
because he obliged her to circumcise the
child and upon this occasion it is
probable he sent them back to his
father-in-law
that they might not create him any
further uneasiness when we have any
special service to do for god
we should remove that as far from us as
we can which is likely to be our
hindrance
let the dead bury their dead but follow
thou mean
it's a possibility
we know that they did return
we don't know the circumstances perhaps
he's reading a bit much in it
if we go to ellicott's commentary for
english readers
it says so let him go
god let moses go allowed him to recover
accepted zippers act as sufficient
albeit tardy
reparation and spared the life of her
husband
then she said when moses was
sufficiently recovered zepera explained
to him why she had called him a bloody
husband it was on account of the
circumcision i.e the two circumcision of
gusham and in midian many years
previously and now elisa
we learned from exodus 18 2-3 that
zipperer and her boys were sent back to
jethro by moses probably at this time so
he basically agrees with with wesley
right
moses was in haste and the child you
know would have been an inconvenience
here's kaufman's commentary
and it came to pass on the way at the
lodging place that jehovah met him and
sought to kill him
then zebra took a flint cut of the
foreskin and she said a bright groom of
blood ought thou because of the
circumcision
so slightly
different translation but basically
that's what the word is a husband the
bridegroom
this means that moses became dangerously
ill so he believes that
it was not a flaming sword
but a disease
and they both understood that there was
something wrong
and they'd probably discussed it and
maybe zipper was a little bit tardy
and didn't want to inflict the child
with the circumcision
and
so god intervened yeah and this is
if you look at it in this scenario it's
almost
similar but different from job
yes
because
there it was the devil yes and there was
a rea
there was no reason for him to be sick
as here there is a reason for him to be
correct
so this is an this is an interesting
analogy
it is clear that zipper's action saved
his life
precisely because it saged the anger of
god he let him go
either moses was
too to circumcise the boy or zebra for
some other reason took the lead and did
it herself my personal feeling is he
wasn't capable or else he would have
done it
right
so he was too sick
but he was sick because he didn't do it
in the first place correct there was a
reason
god met him
god stopped him from doing what he was
going to do
he was the one who was to deliver the
people
and there was something that was a myth
and it had to be corrected right okay
it is quite obvious that the whole
bloody business of circumcision was
repugnant to zebra so he also believes
that she was against the circumcision
and so she called him a bloody husband
or a bridegroom in blood
moses respect for his wife's objections
however was sinful
god is not a respecter of persons
special servants must obey
as well as perform their special tasks
there are other commentaries that say
that she wasn't actually
using derogatory language when she was
saying a bloody husband otta
because the covenant was a covenant in
blood
and that is why the circumcision is so
important because it had that symbolism
it had the symbolism of the circumcision
of the heart
not only for the individual involved but
for the entire offspring
because the husband is the head of the
house right
and
it was a
bloody circumcision
which meant that this
basic priestly duty of the husband in
the house
was
for the whole family
so now you are a
husband in blood to me
in other words we are bound in the
covenant you could read it like that
yeah then it's not a cussing
so whether it was the one or the other
i i prefer the second
because uh it's not quite so
drastic right yes and the outcome
afterwards is the same
or even better because there's no um
hard feelings correct afterwards correct
so she wasn't cussing she was saying
now we have fulfilled the duty and you
have become a husband of blood to me
because of the circumcision
basically that is saying because of the
covenant yeah
all right
so in other words she submitted to it
although she was
reticent
she submitted
because she realized it was an essential
component
of their religion correct
okay let's continue exodus 4 27-31
and the lord said to aaron
go into the wilderness to meet moses and
he went and met him in the mount of god
and kissed him so it's important martin
that god was speaking
to both sides
basically you can say speaking to both
sides to the heart yes the one has a
commission to go and
do something in particular and the other
one had to be cooperative correct
so both sides need an information right
and moses told aaron all the words of
the lord who had sent him and all the
signs which he had commanded him and
moses and aaron went and gathered
together all the elders of the children
of israel
and aaron spoke all the words which the
lord had spoken unto moses and did the
signs in the sight of the people
and the people believed
that's a very nice statement right yes
and when they heard that the lord had
visited the children of israel and that
he had looked upon their affliction then
they bowed their heads and worshiped
all right martin so we have another
little snippet here two sides one has a
message from god
the other one is willing to cooperate
and the people believed
and they worshipped exactly
that's the way it should be
yes did it stay like that
unfortunately no no it didn't stay like
that the intention was good but the
flesh was weak correct
do we have a lesson in that
a very very
deep lesson all right so martin
somebody must have told you
this is what the lord wants
right yes
and you met
that's
someone in a spiritual sense
checked it out for yourself came to the
conclusion it is so
and at some stage you believed correct
and then you said
you'll worship this god yes
and then later did you say all that you
have said i will do
yes okay
well let's go to the spirit of prophecy
that's another source that we can rely
on
with his wife and children moses set
forth on the journey and on the way from
midian moses received a startling and
terrible warning of the lord's
displeasure
an angel appeared to him in a
threatening manner as if he would
immediately destroy him
no explanation was given but moses
remembered that he had disregarded one
of god's requirements
yielding to the persuasion of his wife
he had neglected to perform the right of
circumcision upon their youngest son
so we can be pretty sure
that some of the commentaries actually
got something right right yes
but he didn't get sick
it doesn't say that he didn't get sick
it is true
the angel could also have been there to
make him sick correct you don't know no
so it's possible that he became
incapacitated yes
with whatever ailment it was and it was
so sudden
that he knew
there was something that god was telling
him he didn't even have to say it
he knew it
obviously they had argued about it
correct
he had failed to comply with the
condition by which his child could be
entitled to the blessings of god's
covenant with israel
i like that because
it supports the idea you are a covenant
of blood you are a husband of blood to
me yeah yeah
zipper fearing that a husband would be
slain performed the right herself and
the angel then permitted moses to pursue
his journey
in his mission to pharaoh moses was to
be placed in a position of great peril
his life could be preserved only through
the protection of holy angels
but while living in neglect of a known
duty
he would not be secure for he could not
be shielded by the angels of god
now martin did we choose this
arbitrarily or do you think there is a
typology in this that we should take
note of directly
there's a direct typology to
every person on the planet okay so
what was he doing he was on the way to
pharaoh
now pharaoh is a type of satan
yes
and he's going to meet him head on
well as we approach the end of time
are we going to meet an enemy head on
yes and his representatives correct
it's going to be head on right we're
going to the ship is gonna hit malta
okay
all right now martin what if we are in
neglect of a known duty
can the angels of god shield us no
so
is it very important that we
have some introspection
definitely we if you want to be under
the protection
you have to perform your duty
you have to perform your duty all right
now who had received the instructions as
to what the duty was
moses moses
moses had been called
to call the people out of egypt right
yes
is there an anti-typical moses
that was
instructed by god
to give all the information that the
people in the end time would need to
call them out of antitypical babylon yes
there's an anti-typical moses that have
to give the duty
to the people
correct
all
right uh
is that duty
paramount is it important
yes you can see how important it was in
moses time one little neglect of of a
known duty
and death would be the consequence
correct okay
now aaron being instructed by angels
went forth to meet his brother now you
know when we read that
people have
ideas
where they
literalize this to the sense that you
know he's sitting there and the angel is
sitting next to him and instructing him
no
through the spirit through your thinking
through your words this is how it
operates
they still doing the same today
absolutely every single person that
studies the bible gets instructions from
angels absolutely so when you're sitting
there and you're studying your bible
you say a prayer yes you say lord i
really really want to understand what
you are saying what is your will
angels of god
will
enlighten you
along with the holy spirit the holy
spirit working inside will
bring this to the fore
so it says they'd been instructed by
angels and went forth to meet his
brother
from whom he had been so long separated
and they met amid the desert solitudes
near horeb
together they journeyed to egypt and
having reached the land of goshen they
proceeded to assemble the elders of
israel
so here's a question
martin is god gathering his people for a
confrontation with pharaoh we've already
answered it right yep definitely we're
on our way
how do these words affect us
what if we live in neglect of a known
duty such as
health reform
so god has given his people a message
saying
let's put it bluntly martin
if you want to be able to stand in this
spiritual war
in this conflict of interests in this
clash of minds exactly
i want you to have a clear mind
and therefore i'm going to
in my mercy
give you very specific instructions as
to what is right
and what is wrong
and i want you to do it
and you say
no i don't want to
or
your zipper
says no way am i doing that
and you say well for the sake of peace
in the home
i'm going to listen to zipper
could you have a problem i think most
definitely you
you're going to have a problem you're
going to have a problem right
okay and sorry just to make it clear
you're going to have a problem with god
yes not between you and zephora who
stopped him there guarded yes the one
translation said java stop them there
right
this branch of the lord's work has not
received due attention
and through this neglect much has been
lost
if the church would manifest a greater
interest in the reforms
through which god himself is seeking to
fit them for his coming
their influence would be far greater
than it is now
martin
i want you to think about this
moses was on his way
to a conflict
of interest
it seems to me sometimes that the church
is more on pharaoh's side than it is on
god's side in many of the issues that we
confront yes or confronted in our time i
i don't know does that sound a bit harsh
definitely it doesn't seem to me that
there's any conflict going on
at all it it looks like conformity
rather than conflict right and if like
you said earlier that confrontation is
with pharaoh so at this stage there's
more
um
confrontation with moses yeah correct
yes exactly yeah the spirit of prophecy
is set aside
when we we spoke last time about drugs
right yeah drugs should not be
introduced into the human body that's an
instruction to an anti-typical moses
yeah
and our modern medical fraternity in our
own ranks is saying that was for then it
doesn't apply today the drugs are better
than they were then correct
it's but we had this nobel prizes we're
not saying if you continue to take that
stuff with the skull and the crossbones
on it it's going to kill you exactly and
you can take a very simple medication
take something like
whatever paracetamol
which is basically
in a little tablet that you can even
give to kids right
what if you take 10 of those
at the time
can it cause cirrhosis of the liver yes
big problems can it cause other diseases
and destroy your your system
so even there you will get a long list
of
what they can do right
okay
so martin
if you take the natural
products then the chances of overdosing
are very low right
of course even good food can make you
gag yeah if you eat too much of it
correct
so everything is in moderation
everything has to be
dealt with in temperance
but this issue is very very important
so we are on
our way
we are heading for a clash with pharaoh
so let's continue
to read
although the health reform is not the
third angel's message it is closely
connected with it
those who proclaim the message should
teach health reform also
it is a subject that we
must understand in order to be prepared
for the events that are close upon us
and it should have a prominent place
now martin
i am saddened by the fact
that this church of ours
was
in the forefront it was the head when it
came to health reform yes
it shook the entire world
it changed
the whole dietary system of the entire
world correct
it was completely opposite to the other
medical
news that was
it was the exact opposite
and the entire breakfast industry that
is now in the world
is as a consequence of this church
right correct we still have the name
kellogg
all those products wheat picks
alternatives such as marmite peanut
butter soy milk all of these issues
there is nobody that is not affected
by the health message that went out from
the pioneers of this church
correct correct
and our institutes were to be a model of
god's way yeah and we had sanitariums
and hospitals
and they produced
a product which was totally different to
that of the world
health reform was practiced natural
healing methods
diet sunlight exercise
a plant-based diet
no meat on the table at any of our
sanitariums
drugs were to be avoided at all costs
the intelligent use of water in the
curing of people
fermentations
fever
was to be treated with the intelligent
use of water
etc etc etc
has there been a swing from that
to the side of the world
yeah unfortunately unfortunately yes yes
so when the institute used to be
drug free
today it is not much different from the
world in fact it is so much the same
that you can even form alliances
with pharaoh with pharaoh
and bury the message correct
that is a very very sad state of affairs
satan and his angels are seeking to
hinder the work of reform and will do
all they can to perplex and burden those
who heartily engage in it you know
martin
when we try to raise up
i'm not talking about us now as we but
as a people
institutes of health
and
do they get
the greatest support from everywhere or
do they get tremendous opposition
tremendous opposition martin
is this a known duty that is being
neglected yes
how are we going to face pharaoh and how
the angel is going to protect us
if we continue along this road now if
you continue on it you're not going to
make it you're not going to be able to
stand against pharaoh and god will not
allow it are you being very harsh martin
yes
but i i think you must calm down
i'm
very passionate about it because it's
really something that can change the
body of the of christ all right let me
ask you a question
you're a relatively
new man
in in in this walk right
do you
experience
opposition from without let's say
within your circle of friends from the
past or your family or whatever do you
experience opposition on this point yes
all right let me ask you a terrible
question do you experience opposition
within the church on this point yes
unfortunately yes
so is satan busy
he's not only busy he's succeeding
he's succeeding he's obliterating the
message correct and sometimes people
struggle and they put up a health reform
system
and they get nothing but criticism to
the point where they have to pack up and
leave at the end isn't that a shame
that something like this should happen
in the time that we are living in when
we are right before a confrontation
with pharaoh and we are in a crisis of
health
yes
this is where we're running to are we
running to pharaoh for help or are we
running to god one hundred percent
running we're running to pharaoh
absolutely
testimonies to the church volume one
page 516 the health reform is a branch
of the special work of god for the
benefit of his people
i saw that in an institution established
among us the greatest danger would be
its managers
departing from the spirit of present
truth
and from that simplicity which should
ever characterize the disciples of
christ
when hezekiah was dying
the prophet got an instruction to make a
poultice of fig leaves
i'm sure the medical fraternity called
it quackery correct right
but it got better yes whereas before he
was dying exactly who's in control of
your health martin
yourself and god
i see so god is the one who is the
author of health and you are the one
who's supposed to comply to his world
that's it you make the decision and if
you make the right one god can help
correct a warning was given me against
lowering the standards of truth in any
way in such an institution
in order to help the feelings of
unbelievers and thus secure their
patronage
the great object of receiving
unbelievers into the institution is to
lead them to embrace the truth
now martin
if we have organizations that are
supposed to help people
let's not
use any names here
and the instruction is that we will keep
it strictly secular yes
is that fulfilling god's
purpose absolutely not no the purpose is
to bring them to the truth how do you
bring people to the truth without
speaking truth and demonstrating truth
right correct
or do we just want to have accolades
from the world
we just want to be accepted
if the standard be lowered
they will get the impression that the
truth is of little importance and they
will go away in a state of mind harder
of access than before
but the greatest evil resulting from
such a cause would be its influence upon
the poor afflicted believing patients
who would affect the cause generally
they have been taught to trust in the
prayer of faith
and many of them are bowed down in
spirit because prayer is not now more
fully answered
i saw that the reason why god did not
hear the prayers of his servants
for the sick amongst us
more fully was that he could not be
glorified in so doing while they were
violating the laws of health a known
duty yes
and i believe
we are seeing it
today still
i i believe we are seeing it more than
ever
we're asking for god for praise to heal
our sick yes but we are neglecting our
known duty and because we are not seeing
the results that we hoped for
we run to pharaoh yes
and we ask for his help and the worst is
then we say that the potion that pharaoh
gives is better is from god
now imagine martin if
the potion that has been developed by
pharaoh's priests is attributed to god
would would that be a shocking thing
yes it's a sad state of affairs
all right now let's read a little bit
more
this comes from the spirit of prophecy
volume 4.
i like those old books
because a spade is called a shovel
you know exactly what you're working
with
the sanctification set forth in the
scriptures embraces the entire being
spirit soul and body
paul prayed for the thessalonians that
their whole spirit and soul and body be
preserved blameless unto the coming of
the lord jesus christ again he writes to
the believers i beseech you therefore
brethren by the mercies of god
that you present your bodies a living
sacrifice wholly acceptable unto god
quote in romans 12 1. the jews were
commanded to offer in sacrifice to god
only such animals as were free from
disease or blemish
so christians are required to preserve
all their powers in the best possible
condition for the lord's service says
peter
abstain from fleshly lusts which war
against the soul first peter 2 11
the word of god will make but a feeble
impression upon those whose faculties
are being numbed
by any sinful gratification
the heart cannot preserve consecration
to god while the animal appetites and
passions are indulged at the expense of
health and life
paul writes to the corinthians
let us cleanse ourselves from all
filthiness of the flesh and spirit
perfecting holiness in the fear of god
second corinthians 7 1
and with the fruits of the spirit love
joy peace long suffering gentleness
goodness faith meekness he classes
temperance
health reform has been given
not as a curse but as a gift
exactly it's like the fourth commandment
everybody wants to make it a curse
i was a carnivore right
i've always said that chicken was a
vegetable
i was a carnivore through and through do
you think it was easy to say oh okay all
right let's try this thing you think it
was easy
i was exactly the same
and i can promise you it wasn't easy but
it was easy
when you do it not alone when you do it
with god all right
and now that you have done it
when you started did you get opposition
yes do you still get opposition yes
every single day right
but once you actually did it
did you feel the benefits definitely and
once you got into the group
were you any worse off than you were
before no much better off uh
and for me personally i can never go
back
because i cannot even think of going
back you're on a better road yes and
it's
actually amazing sometimes to me
that
people that argue with you will tell you
no you're you're worse off you're worse
off yes but they don't sit on this side
of the face of it exactly you know
wesley when he was speaking about music
he was a great composer and he loved
music and he brought you know wonderful
music into the church i mean a thousand
hymns or more i don't know how many he
wrote but it was amazing he and his
brother
and one of his complaints was why should
the devil have all the best music
right
in the same way people think
that the devil has the best diet and
god's people are deprived that's true
and he's got you so convinced that when
you switch over you're thinking
nothing but this manner yeah and they
have so twisted it that now the one
that's actually from the devil
is being portrayed as that is from god
correct
now martin it's an absolutely amazing
thing i i conquer with you there's no
way i could go back
in fact
the way that it was is repugnant to me
i don't know what changed
i certainly didn't do it
so somebody must have changed it can i
ask you a question before you're gone
yes how long did it take moses to get
rid of that
mindset of
pharaoh in egypt
40 years so when you were in that type
of diet and you had to change it also
takes some time to cleanse and get
correct all of that out and the
interesting thing is
i got steeped into this research
because once i started realizing the
benefits and i saw the opposition out
there
in fact i had more support from the
outside particularly amongst the new age
world than from with our own within our
own ranks
and this is a very sad state of affairs
and it is to this day still like it
correct
if we go back to the previous
quote
is satan busy he is very busy
she writes here to these people i'm glad
that you are able to help the believers
in norfolk island tell them that health
reform is necessary to a pure clean
breath and pure clean current of blood
tea coffee port and tobacco defile the
users the lord calls upon all who claim
to believe his truth to take their stand
firmly upon bible ground in regard to
health reform there is to be a marked
difference between those who serve god
and those who serve
themselves
now
you take that little word tea and coffee
over there
all right most people that are believers
will agree that tobacco is surely
detrimental
but when it comes to tea and coffee
surely not
i gave a lecture some time ago called
path of obedience
where i showed that it was pharaoh's
agents
his priests
that introduced coffee
that introduced tea
that introduced narcotics into the world
opium
and all of these cocaine
and started the mega industries which
used those products and cocoa and
defiled humanity with it chocolate
all of it
came from pharaoh's agents particularly
his priests the jesuit order that's it
now
martin
we have whole churches that seem to
think it's fine to do these things
and they have
coffee displayed everywhere
and tea and they think it's perfectly
fine there's a very clear admonition
against this kind of thing
and what's also sometimes sad to me is
you'll
you'll get the message that but it's
only coming from the spirit of prophecy
if you read this correct it says there
do your bible study to get to to realize
that this is the
way it should be no not only that the
world will tell you so
they did that that scan that brain scan
and showed that one just one cup of
coffee cuts the blood supply to your
brain by 40 percent martin do you want
to have 40 percent less
cognitive function
you might have a high
but you are certainly going to be
followed by a low yes we actually showed
that video
in a previous what's up prof
guidelines for the discernment correct
so now when we come to the plagues of
egypt there are another few points
basically what we're doing is we're
looking at the progression one neglect
of one known duty and he couldn't face
pharaoh yes right
moses and aaron were god's
representatives to a bold defiant king
and two impenitent priests heartened in
rebellion which allied themselves to
evil angels
we're facing exactly the same situation
today we have impenitent priests
hardened in rebellions who have allied
themselves to evil angels correct you
can see it by what they're preaching
in terms of
denigrating every norm that you have in
the word of god
right
pharaoh and the great men of egypt were
not ignorant in regard to the wise
government of god
because you know they had a history they
had joseph there we don't have to read
it all
so in other words many were placed in
important positions and these were
witnesses for god there were people
there
that knew
some of these truths
satan well knew that moses was chosen of
god to break the yoke of bondage upon
the children of israel and he consulted
with these angels how to accomplish a
work which should answer a two-fold
purpose number one
to destroy the influence of the work
wrought by god through his servants
moses by working through his agents and
thus counterfeiting the true work of god
so whenever you
confront pharaoh
you are going to confront a counterfeit
yeah so if you have a health message
there will be a counterfeit message
which one do you want to run with martin
definitely with the one from god okay
secondly
to exert an influence by his work
through the magicians
which would reach down through all ages
and destroy in the minds of many true
faith
in the mighty miracles and works to be
performed by christ when he should come
to this world
so there will be magicians
there will be magicians in the church
and you think there might be magicians
with white coats as well yes definitely
the king demanded a miracle
in evidence of their divine commission
everybody wants a miracle
so aaron took a rod and cast it down
before pharaoh and it became a serpent
and the monarch said unto his wise men
and unto his sorcerers
it's interesting
that it's called by its name
sorcery
witchcraft
pharmacia who cast down
every man his rod and they became
serpents but aaron's rod swallowed up
their rods the magicians did not really
cause their rods to become serpents but
by magic
aided by the great deceiver they were
able to produce this appearance
it was beyond the power of satan to
change the rods to living serpents the
prince of evil though possessing all the
wisdom and might of an angel fallen
has not power to create or to give life
this is the prerogative of god alone
so when it comes to disease
whose prerogative alone is it to give
life god
okay
the serpent that
aaron produced by throwing down his rod
was a true serpent because it swallowed
up the others yes
but it wasn't enough evidence for
pharaoh right
thus satan's counterfeit accomplished
its purpose of emboldening the egyptians
in their rebellion and causing pharaoh
to harden his heart against conviction
satan hoped also to shake the faith of
moses and aaron in the divine origin of
their mission
the only result was to prepare the way
for greater exhibitions of divine power
and glory and to make more apparent both
to the israelites
and to all egypt the existence and
sovereignty of a true and living god
martin
we are currently in a clash of minds yes
there are two sides
to the story in the world today
and people have to make decisions right
do you think the issue could escalate
and the conflict could become even
greater in the future yes i think we're
on our way it's definitely going to do
that definitely and anybody who denies
it now
i want you to think about this
as the conflict escalated
did pharaoh's heart soften or was it
even more hardened more hardened
so martin if we're not on the right side
of the decision now the conflict is
going to get worse
and worse
and worse are we going to jump sides
from pharaoh to the other side are we
going to say
wow look at
the magicians
and the pharmaceut that he's bringing
forth i'm going to jump to pharaoh's
side
could it have happened here yes
i think it did
sick people who take drugs
do appear to get well with some their
sufficient life force for nature to draw
upon
to so far expel the poison from the
system that the sick having a period of
rest recover but no credit should be
allowed the drugs taken for they only
hindered nature in their efforts all the
credits should be ascribed to nature's
restorative powers
god built those powers into the system
now when i started health reform
and i kicked out the bad habits
i got
incredibly sick yes
because for the first time ever my body
had an opportunity to throw out toxins
correct
my whole skin came off my back
i was as sick as a dog
but that you get accused there
that it was your diet's fault absolutely
all the time
and i lost all that weight
um oh now he became sickly now i was in
a very poor state and people were saying
well that serves you right right you
want to change that your diet
and then when i went through what you
call that healing crisis and came out
the other side i started to pick up
weight again
my strength increased
and
i'm not a spring chicken anymore i can
still move things around and i can still
pick you up if i have to
but
it's just amazing
you know i there was this one one man he
was well in his 80s
and he climbed the mountain every day he
had a mountain behind him and that was
his exercise
and when he was 86 he went to the doctor
and he said to the doctor doctor
i'm struggling
a little more these days to get up this
mountain than i did five years ago and
the doctor said it's your diet
he was 86 years old exactly he's been on
the diet for probably 40 years the
average lifespan of a doctor is probably
around 56
so you know i doubt whether the doctor
would have still been going up the
mountain at that pace
so this just tells you what the mindset
of the people are yeah just for uh in
interest sake how long have you been on
this diet
33 years 33 years well here's a 33 year
example well
you know it's not that you don't get
sick you get sick
and it's not that you don't have
ailments you do have ailments
but you can power through them without
drugs and the thing is
the whole point is like we've listed
we've been reading
it's not only for your health
it's for your clarity of mind that is
the most important thing of all
all right let's read manuscripts 49 in
our sanitariums we advocate the use of
simple remedies we discourage the use of
drugs for they poison the current of the
blood in these institutions sensible
instructions should be given
how to eat
how to drink
how to dress
how to live so that the health may be
preserved you know martin even dress
if for the sake of fashion in the midst
of winter you're going to wear flimsy
clothes to show off whatever asset you
believe should be shown to the world
it's stupidity
nothing short of stupidity and it has a
role to play in hell correct bacteria
love to thrive at a lower temperature
than core body temperature
and because your lung is normally at a
lower temperature because there's
evaporation and you're constantly
breathing in and breathing out the first
organ that is likely to be attacked is
the lung
but if you are very cold and your
extremities are cold you are actually a
breeding ground
for pathogens
so keep your temperature and your core
temperature right
keep your clothing so that it fits the
occasion
and these are all important things so
it's how to eat how to drink how to
dress
in order to preserve life
all right so here's another quote on how
to live when she talks about drugs she
says the disease which the drug was
given to cure may disappear but only to
reappear
in skin diseases ulcers painful disease
joints and sometimes in a more dangerous
and deadly
form
you know martin i was giving lectures in
germany on health issues
and there was a lady in a wheelchair she
was well into her 80s
and in an old age home
and that brought her to the lectures
she changed her lifestyle she was well
in her 80s
and when i returned later
to the same country was germany four
years later she walked up to the stage
and said she's gone back into her
apartment she's out of the old age home
her her fingers were still skew from the
arthritis but all the pain was gone and
she could again
use her limbs properly
it is amazing
what happens when you change your
lifestyle
we've got some the church has got some
institutions in south africa
and the stories because we were quite
involved with one of them that you see
people go in
and how they
are there for 10 days
and their recovery is absolutely
astounding correct
now in those plagues martin
in the seventh plague as predicted there
was thunder and hail and fire mingled
with it destroying every herb shattering
trees etc etc it was the destroying
angel
so sometimes it could be possible that
angels destroying angels are giving
messages to mankind
and they are attributing it to
something else right climate change or
whatever
and then there are statements in this
patriarchs and prophets and in the
spirit of prophecy about what happened
on that
fateful night when the firstborn were
killed
they had very specific instructions
they had to
sacrifice this lamb
and they had to put the blood on the
doorposts and on the lintel and in the
same way we have to put the blood of the
lamb on the doorposts and on the lintels
of our hearts right
and just on a side note here they had to
eat the whole lamb
yes that's why the whole clan came to
bed together and it was done with bitter
herbs it wasn't a
tasty morsel yeah or
instruction as to a dietary
no
it was a typological issue exactly
and so they all had
a small portion
of it
and then at midnight
the destroying angel went and he
destroyed the firstborn now that warning
had gone out right from the beginning
moses already knew that the forced
firstborn
were going to die but he first started
with all the other things the water
turned to blood etc etc etc
now the important thing that we need to
know is that christ
was the invisible leader of israel
in the book the truth about angels we
read in egypt the report was spread that
the children of israel were passing on
towards the red sea
pharaoh collected his forces attended by
the great men of his realm headed
the attacking army now it's fascinating
martin
that when he was attacking god's people
he took the people with him not only the
army no not only the military
the priests were in it it was a
coalition
of church
state
and the people yes
so there was a collective mindset
a babylonian collective mindset let's
rid the planet of our enemy
[Music]
so the hebrews were encamped beside the
sea suddenly they beheld in the distance
the flashing armor and moving chariots
partoking the advance of the great army
terror filled the hearts of israel some
cried unto the lord but the far greater
part hastened to moses with their
complaints are we going to have a
similar experience definitely
are the people going to say
the fanatics amongst you are the ones to
blame for this calamity yep is it
already happening already happening okay
that's very interesting
his calm and assuring reply to the
people was fear you're not stand still
and see the salvation of the lord
the wonderful pillar of cloud had been
followed as the signal of god to go
forward
but now they questioned amongst
themselves if it might not foreshadow
some great calamity
for had it not led them on the wrong
side of the mountain into an impossible
way
thus the angel of god appeared to their
deluded minds as the harbinger of
disaster
martin
when it comes to this final clash
it will appear as if god's people are
surrounded and there is no way out yes
and many will shout
that we've been led in the wrong
direction
and a decree will go out kill them
correct
and you will
if you don't have faith
and if you haven't followed known duty
yes how will angels protect you it
cannot because you'll have a deluded
mind
correct
so martin
here the people of god
are murmuring and muttering
and they haven't even crossed the red
sea yet right
and they're saying have we been led in
the wrong direction yeah have we been
laid in here to die yes have we
received misinformation from god some
people
go so far as to say as we've already
stated
that pharaoh's magicians are the ones
that we should follow because god
realizing how brilliant they were
gave them all the expertise to give us
the drugs to take us through
right yes
so that's how confused you can become
exactly
but then they crossed the red sea
and they they still had a lot of
egyptian in them
and now comes the tricky part
god is trying to educate them to leave
egypt behind yes
they had a constant tendency to go back
to egypt yes they were longing for egypt
they longed for the coffee stalls and
the cocoa
that they had in egypt
and the flesh pots of egypt they were so
delightful right
and all the perverted foods
and now they were put on a different
diet oh
so let's read what happened from then
onwards because this is very important
for our time
exodus chapter 16 verse 7 to 15 and in
the morning
then you shall see the glory of the lord
for that he heareth your murmurings
against the lord
and what are we that you murmur against
us and moses said this shall be when the
lord shall give you in the evening flesh
to eat
they were muttering because they didn't
get any flesh food
and in the morning bread to the full for
that the lord heareth your murmurings
which you murmur against him and what
are we
your murmurings are not against us but
against the lord
so martin they wanted the fleshpots of
egypt and they were murmuring against
moses
antitypically
the people want the fleshpots of egypt
and the coffee bars
and they're murmuring against the spirit
of prophecy that's it
same thing right
and moses spoke unto aaron say unto all
the congregation of the children of
israel come near before the lord for he
has heard your murmurings and it came to
pass as aaron spoke unto the whole
congregation of the children of israel
that they looked towards the wilderness
and behold the glory of the lord
appeared in the cloud and the lord spake
unto moses saying
i've heard the murmurings of the
children of israel
speak unto them saying at even you shall
have flesh
and in the morning you shall be filled
with bread and you shall know that i am
the lord your god let's stop there
did god do the same thing with these
anti-typical people yes
he said to them meat eating is not a
test of fellowship correct
but if you continue in that way
you will lose your discernment
and you will be deprived of a blessing
that could have been yours correct all
right same thing yes so he was obliging
he tolerated it he didn't say throw them
away it's not a test of fellowship okay
it's just interesting to me if i read
here
the flesh didn't fill them
it only for their craving yes the
morning the bread
they were filled because the bread is
the word right that became flesh
all right and it came to pass that in
the evening the quails came up covered
the camp and in the morning the dew lay
around about the host and when
the dew that lay was gone up behold upon
the face of the wilderness
they lay a small round thing
as small as the whole frost on the
ground and when the children of israel
said they saw it they said one to
another it is mana for they waste not
what it was
actually that mean what's it
and moses said unto them this is the
bread which the lord has given you to
eat
so there was something that was good for
them
and something that was bad for them that
he permitted yes
they were complaining against the bad or
against the good
the good
nothing but this manner
this manner and this was the first time
yes
so
anti-typically we're talking typology
right
the lord in his mercy
permitted
the children of israel that had come out
of egypt
to partake in their craving
he discouraged it
he told them they are murmuring against
god but he permitted it do we have an
analogy yes
yes god's people are permitted and
therefore they think it's okay
and they will even tell you that it's
okay exactly
in a most
vociferous manner
okay
but let's continue down the line we're
coming closer to canaan correct
exodus 16 35 and the children of israel
did eat manna 40 years until they came
to a land inhabited
they did eat manna until they came unto
the borders of the land of canaan it's
absolutely essential that we eat the
manna correct we have to internalize the
character of christ but there's also a
health reform message here yes it's part
of his character yes
numbers 11 18-20 and say thou unto the
people sanctify yourselves against
tomorrow
and ye shall eat flesh
now martin this is interesting yeah
they were permitted to eat flesh right
and now comes the second time when they
are murmuring
and craving
flesh
and the first thing he says
sanctify yourselves in other words what
he is saying to the people martin is
think very carefully
and consult
the word to see whether you are on the
right path or not
sanctify yourselves and those that did
sanctify themselves
did not crave the flesh right
tomorrow you shall eat flesh for you
have wept in the ears of the lord saying
who shall give us flesh to eat
for it was well with us in egypt
therefore the lord will give you flesh
and ye shall eat
you shall not eat one day nor two days
nor five days neither ten days nor
twenty days but even a whole month until
it come out of your nostrils and that be
loathsome to you is god for it or
against it well it definitely doesn't
seem like you he's actually telling you
fine you wanted it now
get it all right
now if you actually do it aren't you
defiant yes
okay
because that you have despised the lord
which is amongst you and have wept
before him saying why can we forth out
of egypt
that's pretty plain right he's actually
saddened by this he said
so let's go to numbers 21 verse 5 and
the people spoke against god and against
moses wherefore have you brought us up
out of egypt to die in the wilderness
for there is no bread neither is there
any water and our soul loathes this
light bread
that's an interesting statement it
wasn't heavy on the stomach
you know what's interesting martin
people confuse satiety
with good nutrition
people say
this doesn't satisfy me it doesn't give
me satiety
now what is satiety martin
it's a stomach that doesn't empty it
stays
full
now this is very important
if you eat good food
it goes into your stomach goes out of
your stomach
and goes into your blood
yes right
and you have the energy to run with it
so if you have a breakfast
of grains
and nuts
seeds and fruits
it doesn't take very long to digest and
it goes out into your system
if you have a breakfast of
bacon
and eggs
and portions of meat
it gives you satiety it stays in you
it's satisfying it's not light food
correct it's satisfying but it stays in
the it stays in the stomach so does it
go into your tissues to provide you with
energy takes much longer
much more energy out of your whole
system to do correct so if you want to
run a marathon
are you going to have a breakfast of
bacon and eggs and chops
or are you going to have a breakfast of
fruits and cereals and things like that
well it's amazing you're going to have
the bacon
the cereal in that which
and bananas and things like that so
who's more likely to win the marathon
yeah the guy that
eats the plant-based correct
people love satiety
now one of the foods that provides great
satiety
is cheese
because it takes hours and hours and
hours to digest if you eat fruits and
grains
they're out of your stomach within two
to three hours yes in other words
they're supplying your energy to your
body and you can run with it
you add cheese to the mix it can stain
your stomach for 10 hours that means
that food energy is not available to you
but you feel satisfied right yeah this
stuff doesn't satisfy me nothing but
this light
food
the same arguments are being brought
today as they were as verily in those
days we're living in the same times
but now our soul is dried away and there
is nothing at all besides this manner
before our eyes
so god said to them
go for it eat your stuff
and see how well you are yeah
martin
is there an anti-type coming let's read
numbers 18 31-35 and they went forth a
wind from the lord and brought quails
from the sea
and let them fall by the camp as it were
a day's journey on this side and as it
were a day's journey on the other side
round about the camp and as it were two
cubits high upon the face of the earth
this is amazing
and the people stood up all that day and
all that night and all that next day and
they gathered the quails he had gathered
least gathered ten homers that's all
both full
and they spread them all abroad for
themselves around about the cab
and they were so gluttonous
that they even ate it before it was
fully cooked
yes they ate it while it was still
medium rare correct
and while the flesh was yet between
their teeth
here it was chewed
this is very important the wrath of the
lord was kindled against the people
and the lord smote the people with a
very great plague
and he called the name of that place
kibrot hathawa
because they buried the people that
lusted
martin
if this is the type
are we approaching an anti-type no
we are already there we are in the
anti-times
now martin they're not yet in canaan
they are on the way to canaan
god had permitted them
to indulge their
bad diet
and it was not a test of fellowship no
but now the conflict was going to
come a little bit closer
and god said to them
consecrate yourselves
and the very worst of them before they
even swallowed it so it wasn't the meat
that killed them no it didn't go off it
was their craving yes
that did something to them a plague hit
them
and they died
modern if the antitype
is going to follow the type
and you saying we are already there
when people
that are supposed to know better but
have
rebelled against a known duty
continue to do so yes
and
many of them die
in a plague
as it were
because this was not one of the last
plagues this was just the plague that
struck the people exactly it was a
pandemic in fact that happened
do you think it is possible
that the survivors who were equally
gluttonous but didn't necessarily die
while it was still between their teeth
will accuse the ones who are not
partaking in this
of being the ones that are causing the
downfall yes
didn't they accuse moses of being the
one who is the problem yes he led them
in there to come and die and now this is
also probably his fault do you think it
could happen yes
and who is going to be the most vocal
the people that eat the quails
correct now you know
is it only
the people that eat the quails
that necessarily can get sick or do you
think that others can also get sick you
can also get sick
of course they can also get sick
but the difference is
like we've read earlier when you do your
known duty then at least god can protect
you through his angels and all of this
where if you're not doing your duty
you're not even there's not even a
possibility of it happening all right
let's put a curve ball in here
does the spirit of prophecy tell us
that god will put many
people the elderly and even small
children
to sleep
to spare them
particularly those that
are not strong enough to
go through the times that we are going
towards
so
it can be very confusing exactly so
there can be many
people that are really walking in the
will of god
that in
this kind of situation can be put to
sleep
correct
and that is a confusing issue
it can be confusing but i think that's
when you have to remember the difference
between job and moses
was the problem in job's time it was
satan yes and in moses this time
it was himself
it was the people that were complaining
yeah
so we will have this entire mix in the
time that we are living and people are
dying
and there can be people that are totally
consecrated that are dying and people
are wondering why are they dying is our
message wrong yes
but if we are fortified with the spirit
of prophecy and we understand that god
is
in his mercy
putting some to sleep before the great
confrontation
but many of the rebels
those who have neglected known duty will
also be put to sleep and you have to be
able to distinguish
when you get confronted with these
issues not a diff not an easy task no no
no because like you said
the
the ones that are doing the known duty
will be accused they will be the ones
that accu are being accused and if we go
to psalm 78 verse 18
it says and they tempted god in their
heart
by asking meat for their lust
that's the issue martin
health reform is a very important
component
in this final great battle
psalms 106 14 and 15 but lusted
exceedingly in the wilderness and
tempted god in the desert
and he gave them their request but sent
leanness
into their soul
this is the consequence
leanness
and emptiness and inability to discern
yeah
1 corinthians 10 now these things were
our examples
to the intent that we should not lust of
the evil things as they also
lusted
now
i can concur that people can say
health reform is not the religion
but it's the right arm yes
and it's closely associated with the
message
and it is not an unknown duty no it is a
known duty
and it is
perceived as a negative
correct
when in actual fact it is a positive yes
and you will never know
that it is a positive
until you implement it
one and implement it correctly
uh for instance
if you
i don't like to call it a vegan diet
because there's other connotations it's
a plant-boost whole food plant-based
whole food diet but if you put it in
this way
if you say no animal products
yeah
but
coca-cola doesn't have any
animal products you can have a lot of
bad food that you still eat yes pastries
and lots of cakes and sugars and sweet
things and all of those things yeah all
right you know health reform doesn't
have to be austerity
you must enjoy your food it must be a
delight you must delight yourself in the
abundance that lord the lord has
supplied
and there are ways and means of
preparing
things which are delicious
but nevertheless healthy
it takes effort
just like your spiritual life requires
effort
so your physical life also requires
if you snooze you lose if you don't use
it you lose it
it is like that in every aspect so just
to summarize
the health message is not the gospel but
it is the right arm of the gospel
it is a known
duty
it is in fact a command of god
we have been asked to consecrate
ourselves we have been given
an alternative lifestyle
and an alternative
medical instruction
which is
sorely neglected in the times that we
are living in
and we are following a typology to the
tea
and i am
horrified
to think
that we are on the verge
of the second part of that typology
yes and may god help us to be able to
discern
when these things happen
when people
fall
by your side
and you are wondering what is happening
even within our own ranks
may god give us wisdom to follow
every
known
duty that's right
heavenly father
it is a complex issue
and the physical cannot be separated
from the spiritual
just like the arm cannot be severed from
the body without great loss
father give your people wisdom in the
time that we are living in
and help us
to steep ourselves
in the word of god
and to partake daily of that light food
because your yoke is light
so that we may discern
between right and wrong in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears
click again to get notifications to
watch the next video
click here
thank you